and that's eventually how we got to lucy
hale who stars in the film and that's
then who gave
us the ability to to get the film made
because you know her name has value and
then it becomes an actual kind of a real
thing and so
what is a proof of concept short film a
proof of concept short film is basically
making a short or it could be something
even like a teaser or trailer but but
basically showing
what you can do and what you want to do
in the feature version
so
in my case i had written this feature
script uh that i wanted to go make
but i hadn't made i had made this first
feature when i was 17. i was now i don't
know 34 at the time when i was trying to
make this feature
and
i didn't really have any kind of recent
narrative work to show i had been making
commercials for the last almost 10 years
but a lot of that isn't really
transferable to narrative storytelling
in the same way and so i knew kind of i
needed to basically prove
not necessarily to myself but to the
people that were gonna fund this film
that i could make this film um
and so
and a lot of people were telling me that
too and so i decided to basically
make a short film kind of inspired from
my feature that would show
the style and the tone and kind of the
the vibe i was going for and then
showcase my filmmaking as a director
and so
i think that is super important for
young filmmakers because
unless you have a whole collection of
really great short films
and even if you do if it's the different
style or tone than the feature a lot of
times people just won't have the faith
that you can do that right and that's a
separate issue
in general hollywood probably should
have a lot more faith in people and take
some more risks but unfortunately they
don't and so you really kind of have to
prove to people that you can do this and
so
for me to get my future off the ground
it was essential to have made this proof
of concept because
it was probably a 12 15 minute long film
i had taken kind of a character from the
feature and wrote
a kind of back story for them and it was
so it wasn't a scene from the film
it wasn't a teaser but it was kind of
like a almost a prequel to the feature
um
of kind of an origin story of one of the
characters in the feature
and so it could be its own standalone
thing the nice thing about doing that
way is it could be its own short it
could live on its own even if the
feature never happened or did happen it
could still exist it wasn't like a
teaser or a trailer or something like
that it was a full film short film
but it was
totally in alignment to the feature in
terms of the cinematography the pacing
the kind of acting
um just the whole style i was trying to
create and showed that i could pull off
these scenes you know
and it had a little bit of action but
but it kind of showed that kind of my
ability as a director
and it just opened up so many more doors
in terms of
people don't want to read scripts you
know everyone has a script even if
you're just good they still don't want
to read it probably you know because
they don't think it's good and so but if
you can show them if you can send them a
link and show them
a 12 or 15 minute short film that's
compelling and has some talent to it
then they'll be like okay that's
actually pretty good actually i will
read this script now and and then that's
what kind of started to for me
build more and more opportunities for
getting my feature made was was then
people would watch the short and then
they would read the script and i also
had like a deck that i went with along
all this where it was like you know it
was my kind of
vision and take for how to make the
movie in terms of breaking down the
cinematography the music the editing the
same kind of skills i learned from
making commercials where you have to
kind of make a a treatment or a pitch
for why you should direct that
commercial it was that same kind of
thing but for my own movie of like you
know what it would look and feel like so
together that was kind of my package i
would send to people and i didn't have
any agent or manager or barely knew
anyone i was just kind of
taking any kind of connections and
relationships i did have and seeing
where it could go from there and it took
a long time it took several years and
eventually someone would get it and
they'd pass on to somebody else
um
and in my case
a producer saw the short really liked it
then he read the script he really liked
that
and he brought in his casting director
that he works with all the time and
together they were able to get the
script out to some of the the bigger
agencies and that's eventually how we
got to lucy hale who stars in the film
and that's a then who gave
us the ability to
get the film made because you know her
name has value and then it becomes an
actual kind of a real thing and so
none of that would have happened without
this proof of concept short film
so was the backstory about was it ellie
is that her character no it was one of
the other characters it was the
guillermo it was the
the guy who was the character who in the
feature
is is living
in the u.s and receives the drugs um
uh that come via this ultralight
airplane into the u.s but in the short
it was kind of how he got to the us he
was the guy flying the plane in that
case
but kind of
has to
take over he has to basically kill the
guy and replace him and take over and be
the permanent guy and leave his family
behind and and be that guy in in the us
now and so
um it didn't really have a story
connection so much of the feature but it
just had that kind of world connection
and that kind of tone connection and
everything like that
what comes first a proof of concept
short or a screenplay i think the the
screenplay would have to come first
because
without the the screenplay a proof of
concept would just be making a short
film a regular short film which is fine
you can you could use that still to help
your career and build you the next thing
but really the point of a proof of
concept is to
show
that you can then
make this kind of style or this kind of
film that you're trying to make
and i'm talking about in this situation
if you're a writer director like i am
where i had written this
script and i knew i wanted to direct it
i didn't want to just have someone else
make this i wrote this really in order
to direct it um
and so
yeah i think it's it's always has to
start with the script um and maybe if
you have made enough short films or
something similar style you wouldn't
have to do that but for me i just hadn't
made anything narratively
uh in so long that i just really needed
to show something to people
and also i i knew i could make this but
i just i knew that to be able to go out
and pitch this i needed to be able to
show
that i could make this kind of film and
that it could be really great and and
and it was so essential in order to to
have gotten the film made i think to
have had this
and so it was the story of guillermo not
ellie who's actually the protagonist in
the film and where did you film the
proof of concept
so the proof of concept we filmed in
like palmdale lancaster area the movie
the movie the feature borrego is set in
the anza borrego desert in southern
california
and so was the short but
to film out there is a lot further more
expensive so for the proof of concept we
filmed it all in palmdale lancaster
which is closer to la it's kind of the
closest kind of desert you can get to
from about an hour or so drive from la
and that's where we shot it i think it
was two or three days shoot and
you know i i obviously called in lots of
favors um
but i think it is important with the
proof of concept that it still has to
look and feel as real as possible so
if you can't wrangle together the
resources to make it um
compelling
and professional i think it's probably
not worth doing it's it's better to kind
of find something that you can do
because for me i think it's of course
they don't expect it to be look like a
million dollar movie of course but it
still has to has to kind of be able to
look and feel kind of what you're going
after in my case the film needed to be
this very polished kind of traditionally
shot kind of film you know slower kind
of dolly moves and you know things like
that and so
we needed to shoot on really nice
cameras and and put as much resources as
we could into it and so
um it's always that balance because of
course that costs money and most people
don't have that so you have to either
find that money somehow call in favors i
kind of did all the above you know i got
a few people to believe in that project
who gave me a little more money and then
i called in tons of favors from all the
people i had hired over the years to
make commercials and had worked for me
you know and so
together i was able to put together
something that looked really nice you
know it looked really high quality but
was made for not very much money
and
then i was able to eventually get the
film made from that
and are there rules on the time length
of a proof of concept no there's no
rules but i think the general thing with
short films is the shorter is the better
because
especially well for two things one is
for festivals it's always easier to get
a shorter film program to do a festival
because
you know there's only so much time there
is in a festival screening block right
and if your film is 30 minutes long
that's a really big chunk of time you
could put you know a bunch of other
shorter films in that same amount of
time and so
one is if you want to get into festivals
i think shorter is always better and
then two if you're trying to get
executives or financiers or anyone like
that to watch your movie if it's shorter
again they have shorter attention spans
if it's shorter and compelling i think
it's always going to be stronger so i
think mine was 12 or 15 minutes it's
probably the longer end of things where
you'd want it to be but in my case i was
trying to show a couple different styles
of scenes and filmmaking so i needed it
to be that length but
in general if you can keep it short i
think it's always going to be easier
sell for people to watch it